[Musique]
il ya laurent baffie laurent tu mettrais
une note agile sans rigoler ces rites
équipe et mon chéri tu mettras la note m
laurent 3-0 à jean par méchanceté mais
si nous mêmes ces enquêtes sont
partielles et partiales
bref pour moi c'est une question
[Applaudissements]
et le diagramme aimé que des notes voilà
qui méritait bref vous parlez de qui
justement les écrits de qui vous parlez
et gilles verdez mais là malheureusement
je mets 1 2
[Applaudissements]
l'année passée pas notre public sert à
personne et rassoit personnes ils savent
que je regardais c'est vachement cher il
va taper sur tel endroit et maintenant
ce jour-là il tape sur autre chose qui
me fait penser à un arrosage de jardins
je les aime profondément dans la vie je
n'oublie pas qu'au ski on a bien
compagne sonné ensemble bref c'est mon
poto ils sont pas dieu mais qu'est ce
que vous avez vu sur matthieu delormeau
homophobes les freiner
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs de me demander ni rennes
comme ça dans le privé aussi bayonnais
jean burelle passe devant les demandes
des gens qui est vrai que j'ai fait des
non mais laurent était souple est un
souci on se calme pas je veux attention
donc si l'on connaît
énormément d coût total se calme au
lotus est jetée au plus et amandine et
les gens les cotisations à rouiba là oui
monsieur
non mais ça va vraiment le monde se
trompe ce nombre j'en ai mon avis elle
dit je condamnerai laurent bâtisse est
mon ami j'appelle pratiquement tous les
jours ce grossiste men 2 aux siens de
ton père laurent bastide que j'appelle
pratiquement tous les jours 06 12 ouais
faut s'arrêter parce que toi parce que
je voulais garder ce numéro a laissé
weill et le début en plus l'ambiance qui
a avant l'émission et pendant l'émission
est exactement la même je vous jure que
c'est vrai vous vous voyez on est on
fait que en fait on sait on fait que les
cas les conneries laurent je m'en bats
les couilles à un terme hier soir m6
diffusait un nouvel épisode d' enquête
exclusive consacré au multi
millionnaires du loto qui sont sauriez
si vous gagner au loto bab laurent
baffie jour j'arrêterai la télé ouais
déjà c'est vrai oui on vous amuser avec
thierry oui oui beaucoup beaucoup mais
je comprends pas pourquoi vous continuez
vous
si vous tirez gagner au loto flash back
et notamment vous travaillez comme un
con
[Musique]
alors est ce que vous comprenez bien
bougé la chatte jamais si vous deviez
animé des émissions sas à laquelle
j'aimerais bien faire qui veut gagner
des millions
pourquoi parce que c'est une mécanique
formidable et je me verrais bien là
dedans une fois pour essayer ça marrant
ouais j'y crois dit en gros ça serait au
la fibre innocent et va proposer mais
jean pierre foucault vous et jean-pierre
pourquoi il lâchera pas sa place jean
pire mais il est très bon dans
l'exercice et il est excellent mais
jean-pierre il partage c'est un amour il
pourrait beaucoup et je sais je fus
baiser sa femme
et bill & bim colombe assez dit la femme
de jean pierre keller milanais jusqu'à
l'embrasser
c'est un ami bien sûr monsieur jean
pierre foucault on peut être échangé
cette école dynamique en fait j'ai une
petite surprise pour vous mon lolo tout
à l'heure c'était une grosse surprise
ouais mais c'est une grosse surprise
vous êtes un homme au grand coeur mon
lolo et vous soutenez entre autres
l'association handi'chiens dans les
cévennes fait beaucoup de choses pour
eux dites nous un en quoi ça consiste
on va remettre le 2000e chien au
printemps prochain bas c'est un chien ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent et il ya des
gens pas prince milon 15000 pas
forcément des enfants il ya des gens sur
des fauteuils roulants qui attendent à
une présence de vie à un ami un
compagnon et un chien peut reconnaître
cinquante deux ordres
et ça change la vie pour toi assisté une
fois un remise à une remise de chiens
dans sa vie pour comprendre l'émotion
que ça génère j'ai fait c'est
extraordinaire alors est ce vous parle
d'une jeune fille lors regarder leurs
bons vins bien dès lors leur vouloir
vous la connaissez oui alors vous la
connaissez bien laurent que je crois que
ces basses et des gens qu'on voit au
téléthon et puis avec lesquelles
quelqu'un pour qui vous plaît beaucoup
c'est des gens qui ont gardé contact
oui je sais mais elle nous a contactés
lors elle savait que vous veniez
aujourd'hui et elle voulait vous
annoncer quelque chose ici sur le
plateau de touche pas à mon poste et
elle est là ce soir elle a tenu à venir
directement sur place vous l'annoncer
parce qu'après le corps non mais là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une horde est là
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là alors je sais que c'est
toi qui a tenu à être là ce soir c'est
un nouveau ep ajustements alors l or tu
as un truc annonce alors en fait un truc
a annoncé de merci d'être là normalement
malheureuse les caresser ses nerfs si
vous l avez côté que l'homme est alors
lolo alain truc est annoncée en fait ça
va nous raconter toute l'histoire louis
fait comme tu le sais j'attendais un
nouveau compagnon
et ben voilà c'est chose faite et c'est
grâce à toi un peu laurent parce que
tout ce que tu fais pour l'association
du magic mais jade il est arrivé dans ma
vie c'est ma pierre précieuse mon
handi'chiens est pour moi plus qu'un
chien comme tu le sais et c'est grâce à
toi assez les gens comme toi
grâce aux bénévoles oui aux familles
d'accueil que nous pouvons nous
personnes à mobilité réduite retrouver
une vraie place de citoyen donc au nom
de l'association des familles d'accueil
de cette belle chaîne de la solidarité
en tulle c'est andy fiancée une grande
famille et je voulais infiniment te
remercier pour tout ça
alors m
un amour regarde vraiment c'est l'or qui
nous a contacté laurent il face à
l'iphone d'apple et après que moi oui
mais voilà tous les bénévoles bon
travail formidable
vraiment bravo à ce qu'offre la tâche ô
oui ça fait jaser j'ai déjà dit jamais
que votre mère est là des magasins et
cinémas pierres précieuses ah bah ça
c'est à pierre précieuse voilà bah c'est
une amie quand juste après le téléthon
c'est que c'est un moment très important
pour nous en tant que malades et des
familles est basse et chiens il nous
transporte notre quotidien et grâce à ça
on est plus autonome et aussi c'est un
véritable vecteur de communication
c'est-à-dire est génial avec moi j'ai
quelque chose à jazz il ya là quelque
chose à dire
alors oui j'ai dit j'ai dit à ma famille
ça c'est bien moi je crois qu'il n'est
pas utile burden est en fait l'aboiement
déjà dit que ça veut peut dire merci
d'avoir 4 pouce aux familles d accueil
aux bénévoles et les tons n'hésitez pas
à rentrer dans la grande et belle
famille de dans les chiens on a besoin
de deux familles d'accueil pour que
d'autres personnes comme moi puissent
bénéficier de cette aide
merci
merci d'avoir été avec nous
ah bon boulot bravo on saura lire merci
merci à tous
donnez vous dire quelque chose c'est
l'or l'or a dit quelque chose de très
très important à la parler du territoire
indique le téléthon c'était très très
important et c'est à vous qu'on doit
aussi voilà toutes ces têtes qu'il ya
autour du téléthon autour de deux
personnes malades donc merci à vous
d'avoir encore donné pour le téléthon
d'être formidable au design fort on va
regarder si laurent je sais que là c'est
ici ça me fait plaisir comme un festin
regardait ce que l'on rentre à la
demande du préfet molle au taquet